christine lagarde the european central
bank president has some really choice
words about cryptocurrencies in the last
couple of days on a recent episode of
college tour a european talk show she
started talking about cryptocurrencies
and how she thinks they're worthless but
then she hit us with the dichotomy and
so first if christine lagarde the
european central bank thinks bitcoin is
worthless why exactly is that well
here's what she said the first thing was
she said my very humble assessment is
that it is worth nothing great very
descriptive then she went on to state it
is based on nothing there is no
underlying asset to act as an anchor of
safety and sure maybe that's true or
maybe it's not but if christine legard
and other central bankers in europe
actually believe that bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies are worthless then the
conversation basically would stop there
and the market will ultimately prove
them right and those assets will end up
being worthless right well there's a
catch the ecb and christine lagarde they
also want to regulate bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies she went on to say in
that exact same talk show that i'm
concerned about those people who think
it's going to be a reward who have no
understanding of the risks who will lose
it all and who will be terribly
disappointed which is why i believe that
they should be regulated now of course
in this scenario there's two different
paths that you can pursue the first is
that the central bankers actually do
believe that these assets are going to
end up being worthless and they simply
want regulation in place to try to
prevent people from buying them or the
second is that the central bankers don't
actually believe that these are going to
be worthless assets and instead they
realize they can't shut it down there is
no grounds for them to stop the free
market competition between the central
bank assets and these new digital assets
and instead in that scenario they simply
want to regulate them so that they can
get some level of control
now the central bankers will tell you
they don't actually believe there's any
value here but i think that reality is
closer to they understand that there's
value and they simply want regulation in
place so they can still have some
semblance of control regardless of what
happens saying something's worthless and
then making a case for regulating it
doesn't make a lot of sense we simply
are watching them talk out of two sides
of their mouth central bankers they have
their hands full they're going to have
to deal with the changing macro
landscape they literally are trying to
figure out what their monetary policy is
going to be for the next decade and at
the same time they have that nagging
nagging industry of bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies at their heels it'll be
fascinating to watch how this plays out
but christine lagarde making sure
everyone knows bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies are worthless and she
also wants to regulate them hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time